le combat continue pour l'instituteur et
son avocat quatre mois après la levée de
sa mise en examen et son passage en
témoin assisté eric tu es que les
impatiences le dossier pour viol est
toujours ouvert à son nom
malgré la découverte d'une tache de
sperme sur la culotte de la petite fille
et l'adn d'un membre de la famille
déceler toujours pas d'autres mises en
examen
j'ai l'impression qu'on essaye aussi un
petit peu de nous endormir vous dire
vous inquiétez pas ça suit son cours
mais je reviens là en mars l'année
dernière cet élément-là été versées au
dossier et on est un an plus tard
l'espace sur rien donc il c'est une
réalité sa partie civile dans le dossier
l'association innocence en danger menace
de réclamer le dessaisissement du juge
d'instruction
elle réitère sa demande d'un
administrateur ad-hoc pour l'enfant
actuellement le même avocat défend à la
fois la victime est le principal suspect
au delà des maltraitances sexuelles qui
continue dans ce dossier puisque nous
avons des constatations sur cette petite
fille de sept mois après les faits
dénoncés
tout cela est rappelé aux juges
d'instruction comme vous voulez dans
près de 15 pages et je crois qu'il est
grand temps d'arrêter l'autruche l'un
est de protéger cette petite fille dans
son arrêt du 15 novembre dernier la
chambre de l'instruction indique que les
éléments qui ont guidé les enquêteurs
ont perdu de leur pertinence en raison
des deux expertises adn est la vie donc
le juge a réorienté ses investigations
sur le proche de l'enfant pourtant
depuis pas de nouvelle ouverture
d'information judiciaire
le code existent ils il oblige à
magistrat quand il a dans un dossier des
charges graves ou concordants laissant
vraisemblable qu'une infraction a été
commise a aidé à mettre en examen ça
c'est une obligation c'est pas une
faculté
tous les éléments sont là les analyses
je devrais même pas avoir analysé ce
dossier je ne devrais même pas à fournir
plus de vente âge de conclusion un juge
d'instruction c'est son travail à à la
base ce n'est pas le mien
or aujourd'hui je le fais mon confrère
le fait nous n'arrêtons de multiplier
les courriers des analyses
dans ce dossier donc là il ya une
volonté manifeste de ne pas les lire de
ne pas les entendre
et là ça m'interroge sauf que nous avons
une petite fille qui potentiellement si
ce n'est sûrement continuer à être
agressés à être maltraité et si un jour
un drame surgit là il y aura des
responsabilités à les chercher et les
magistrats ne sont pas exemple de ces
responsabilités là joint par téléphone
le procureur eric mathais nous indique
que la demande d'administrateur haddock
du 6 octobre n'a pas été rejeté mais est
toujours à l'étude
il précise qu'il conçoit que ce délai
peut paraître long et que cela
sceptiques en partie par une situation
particulière à dijon où il manque des
justes d'instruction une réponse qui ne
peut satisfaire ni l'instituteur ni des
associations de défense de l'enfance